what we have here is six examples of
possible surveys that might be conducted
what we want to do is is critique them
see whether they're actually doing
things that will give meaningful results
or results that you can actually make
some judgment based on so let's read the
directions it says comment on the way
the following samples have been chosen
for the unsatisfactory cases suggest a
way to improve the sample choice all
right so a you want to find whether
wealthier people whether wealthier
people have more nutritious diets by
interviewing people coming out of a
five-star restaurant so this is skewed
on on two directions one if you're only
if you're only interviewing people out
of a five-star restaurant you're going
to have a disproportionate number of
wealthy people and even the the non
wealthy people who are eating at the
five-star restaurant they feel like they
have enough money to eat there so
they're probably not that not wealthy
they're probably pretty pretty close to
the threshold of wealthy the other skew
is that you're interviewing people at a
restaurant
so you're disproportionately probably
going to get people who eat out as
opposed to people who cook for
themselves and depending on whether this
is a really healthy restaurant maybe
it's some type of organic vegan who
knows what restaurant where you're going
to get a disproportionate number of
healthy people or maybe it's a really
unhealthy restaurant maybe it's a it's
it's you know they put a lot of butter
and sugar and the foo who knows what it
what it's all about but this seems
queued on two dimensions the best way to
do it is survey some proportion of
wealthy people in an environment where
it isn't being skewed by the type of
food they eat so you once again you
wouldn't want to survey people at the
organic grocery because once again you'd
be skewing for people who maybe eat a
little healthier you'd want to do it you
know maybe at some type of wealthy type
of event or something that's not food
oriented I'd have to think more about
what that might be and and you'd also
want to survey people who are not
wealthy so at some other type of event
where most of the population doesn't
fall under the wealthy category or it's
probably the best
would be sampling people at an event
that doesn't discriminate on wealth and
just surveying people and just ask them
in you know in a broad bucket you make
more than X whatever your definition of
wealthy is or is your wealth or do you
is your income less than X and then ask
people what do they eat on a daily basis
something like that might work so in
general I'm not a fan not a fan I don't
think this passes muster it's it's it's
biased on on really two dimensions B you
want to find out if there is a if there
is a pedestrian crossing needed at a
certain intersection by interviewing
people walking by that intersection so
this is better than the first survey but
it still seems a little biased and it
depends what you know how you define
needed is needed if the people walking
around that pedestrian crossing think
it's needed then this is okay but if you
want to objectively find out whether
people in your community think it's
needed you want to have a broader sample
so you might want to also include
drivers because obviously the pedestrian
crossing is going to effects that affect
them you want to interview you know tax
payers in general and obviously a lot of
people might be all of the above and you
also might be missing pedestrians who
would be walking by that intersection if
there was a pedestrian crossing but
they're avoiding it and so those are the
people who would want it the most but
they're not even gonna be there because
they don't think that it's worth walking
around there cuz you can't cross the
street so you're missing a whole sample
of people the best way I would do this
is I would look within a maybe a three
block radius or maybe a six block radius
at all of the homes and offices and I
would randomly survey a sample of those
people and I think that would be a
better indication of whether the
pedestrian crossing is needed and
actually even a better way would be do
it without a survey you would actually
want to look at you know patterns of
people walking and all of that and
compared to other other things that
might be needed but this one definitely
doesn't definitely doesn't work for me
now see you want to find out if women
talk more than men by interviewing an
equal number of men
and women that seems reasonable
I guess if your survey if you do it in a
non biased environment you know if you
don't do it at like a you know a
business school or a law school where
people might talk disproportionately or
it might be skewed towards women or men
uh more I don't know which way it would
be skewed but as long as you do it in a
neutral place and I guess their survey
is maybe they'll ask some arbitrary
question and they'll just time you will
just order this little count how many
words the women talk versus the number
of words the men talk that seems like a
reasonable way to see if women talk more
than men and as once again as long as
you're not talking to you know some
skewed sample or by a sample this seems
pretty good and it's good it's an equal
number there's an equal number of men
and women in the world this seems to be
no give it a I'll give it a smiley face
I'll give it a smiley face right here
dee dee you want to find whether
students in your school get too much
homework by interviewing a stratified
sample of students from each grade level
well the first thing I wanna do is just
you know what what is what is a
stratified what is a stratified sample
and all that means is you're going to
sample people in the same proportion
that they exist in the population so
let's say that your population your
school had you know say it had a hundred
a hundred ninth graders it has two
hundred two hundred tenth graders three
hundred three hundred eleventh graders
and four hundred twelfth graders
actually the school I attended actually
had it went in the reversal or I think
we had like you know eight hundred ninth
graders and four hundred twelfth graders
since so many people dropped out but
anyway we don't have to be realistic
here so you had a total school
population of about one one thousand one
thousand students so if you want to do a
stratified sample let's say you wanted
to have a sample size of let's say 50
students so you wanted a sample 50
students and you wanted you to be a
stratified sample what that means is you
had a hundred ninth graders out of a
thousand in your school so 10% of your
school's population is ninth graders so
and then your stratified sample 10% also
need to be ninth graders so 10%
of five sorry 10% of 50 is five so you'd
survey five ninth graders five ninth
graders in both situations this is 10%
this is 10% of you could view it this is
10% of the population is going to be 10%
of your sample
likewise you had 20% where tenth graders
in the population so 20% of your sample
or 20% times 50 is 10 tenth graders 10th
graders should be surveyed and then 30%
of your of your school is 11th graders
so 30% of your survey so that should be
15 11th graders and then finally 40% or
12th graders so in this situation 40% of
your survey which is 20 should be 12th
graders so that's all that's what a
stratified sample means now let's talk
about whether this is actually a good
survey you want to find out whether
students in your school get too much
homework an you're interviewing students
in your school the one thing you
definitely will find out is you will
find out whether students in your school
think think they think they get too much
homework by interviewing a stratified
set that would be true that's what you
would find out now whether you could say
that you know in a broader sense they're
getting too much homework you might want
to include a larger audience and
especially the other stakeholders and
the whole homework doing process
especially parents parents and teachers
and actually a better way to do it would
be probably to compare the students in
your school to a very similar school
that has a different amount of homework
and maybe see the results on
standardized tests and you want to
control you want to make sure that there
isn't you know a huge difference between
the income levels or the education
levels of the kids parents and all that
I mean it becomes much more involved but
this one still seems a little bit narrow
and all you're going to find out is
whether students think they get too much
homework and I can almost guarantee you
they will think that they get too much
homework
and so this survey might be a little bit
of a waste of time so I will put a
frowny face II you want to find out
whether there should be more public
buses running during
shower by interviewing people getting
off the bus so once again what you're
gonna find out is whether people who
ride people getting off the bus think
there should be more buses you know so I
don't write it here but you're not gonna
find out objectively whether there
should be more buses frankly the best
way to evaluate that I think is to just
see how full on average the bus is I
would actually pull the actual buses and
see how full they are doing rush hour if
they're like you know if if 90% of them
are a hundred percent full and and you
know or people can't get on a bus
because they are full and that's
happening frequently and their total
wait time is just getting ridiculous
that's probably a better assessment than
just surveying people but even beyond
that this is skewed on a set on several
levels one you are surveying only the
people riding the bus you're not
surveying the other people in the
community who might have an opinion on
this drivers taxpayer's you know who
would have to pay for more buses and
then even when even a month within the
bus riding population you have to think
about when they're getting off the bus
if you're getting people off the bus
during rush hour I can almost guarantee
you that they're gonna say yeah we'd
like more buses because they would have
less wait time and the buses would be
less crowded and they wouldn't have to
sit next to anybody so they're even if
it's not needed they're gonna say it is
but if you interview people maybe
getting off the bus during lunch time
who don't use the bus during rush hour
they might say no we don't need more
buses at rush hour we need more at
lunchtime so you're gonna get different
answers depending on when the people are
getting off the bus and obviously gonna
get very different answers from people
not riding the bus so if you want a
broader audience if you're kind of the
you know the city councilman trying to
figure out what to do I once again like
the crosswalk I would survey a random
sample of people within you know three
miles of the bus route or what something
like that and I think that might be a
better result F F I'll switch colors you
want to find out whether children should
be allowed to listen to music while
doing their homework by interviewing a
stratified sample of male and female
students in your school
once again stratified sample just means
that look if my school is 60% male than
60% of my sample will be male and that
doesn't really seem relevant here F
seems very simple
to the do students think they get too
much homework just as you know almost
every students gonna say they get too
much homework almost every student
should say they should be allowed to
listen to music if they want to and
that's not going to be that's not really
going to answer the question of whether
children should be allowed if you want a
broader sample you might just like the
situation with the homework include
include parents include parents and
include teachers but really if you
wanted to answer this question the best
way would actually be to to look at to
survey students who listen to music
while doing their homework and students
who don't listen to music while doing
their homework and see their relative
grade performance and that might give
you a better answer so once again I
think you know this one this one's a
little weak and that's the bus one was
also a little weak so the only good one
here if it's done right is see the other
ones they all needed a little bit of
work to actually be you know surveys
that would give meaningful information